the dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a Targaryen Civil War
where my ancestors danced away my
Birthright
Before the War House Targaryen counted
18 Dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over
till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the dragon video well my
friends with only a few days left
remaining in this season it looks like
the final episode of House of the Dragon
has already leaked online now I haven't
seen the episode yet but fans are
already discussing it all over social
media this is actually nothing new with
HBO damn near every season of Game of
Thrones had something leak way ahead of
their schedule it honestly does kind of
suck when the last episode releases
online early because it ends the season
way sooner than most of us would like as
much as we all want to see how the show
does end none of us actually want it to
be over either if you don't already know
I will be making videos even when the
show goes off the air like I do with
every season of Game of Thrones or now
House of the Dragon I will be making
videos during the entire off season so
don't go anywhere yet I have a lot to
discuss while they're making the second
season and as always I will make videos
about the making of the second season
every step of the way I follow
everything they do while they're hiring
new actors or filming new scenes and so
on and so forth now HBO did release a
lot of new high definition photos from
the final episode and it does look like
most of the leaks from the beginning of
the season are accurate as well once
again the new photos show rainey's
Targaryen as she arrives back on
Dragonstone to inform renera of her
father's death in aegon's recent
coronation in King's Landing now if
you've read Fire and Blood then you know
this shocking revelation will send
ranera into labor a lot sooner than she
should be as some of you might have seen
in one of my recent videos then you know
rhaenyra and Damon's daughter will not
survive in these other photos you can
see the funeral ceremonies being held
outside of the castle on Dragonstone now
since the scene is during the day it
must happen right before or shortly
after Rainer is given her father's Crown
from one of the Cargill Brothers of the
King's Guard he will bend his knee and
swear filthy to renera and join her
black Council there are a lot of new
photos showing the black council meeting
inside of Dragonstone in these scenes
they will discuss who their allies are
and how the they will attack King aegon
and everyone else who stands with them
Dragonstone
princess rhaenyra summoned her own black
counts
council with her was her uncle and
husband Daemon Targaryen considered by
many to be the most dangerous man in
Westeros
few Lords supported her but the greatest
of these was Corliss Valerian who
controlled the largest Fleet in the
realm and his Targaryen wife rhaenys the
old King's sister then there were her
five Sons although none grown to manhood
pitiful assembly really combined they
couldn't match the power of house high
tower alone but rhaenyra had dragons
she Damon and rhaenys rode huge and
formidable beasts and three of her five
Sons were Riders as well
during the episode we now know for a
fact that it is Serato who arrives on
Dragonstone with an offer from King's
Landing obviously they will want
rhaenyra to bend her knee and according
to the leaks she will consider their
offer the one thing that helped sway her
is the letter Otto gives her from
Ellison it's actually from one of the
history books they read in the godswood
when they were a lot younger and great
friends rhaenyra will then inform Damon
of aegon's dream and how he foresaw this
great threat in the north Beyond the
Wall this information will make Damon
very angry either he outright doesn't
believe it or he's mad because no one
ever said anything to him later in the
episode renera will hold another black
council meeting where they will discuss
some of the other major allies they will
need to get on their side as I've said
in other videos Lady Aaron of the veil
Lord Stark of Winterfell and Lord
Baratheon of storm Zen have yet to
declare for either side this is when
rhaenyra's Sons Jason Luke will
volunteer to hand deliver their mother's
message to these houses themselves she
will allow them to go so long as they go
as Messengers only she does not want
them engaging in any other fighting not
only are they still very young but their
dragons aren't very big either in
another one of these official photos we
do see lucari's valerion has arrived at
Storm's end we can see his hair is wet
while he has his hand on his sword it
seems that something has made him
nervous and ready to defend himself and
that's because aemon one eye Targaryen
had arrived at Storm's end several days
before him unfortunately for Lou carries
amond and Lord Baratheon have already
made a deal during this scene aemond
will threaten Luke and demand an eye for
an eye as you all know it was lucarius
who injured aemon's eye when he slashed
him with the dagger so as you can
imagine aemon is looking for a fight but
Lord Baratheon will not allow any blood
to be shed inside of his Hall that's
when lucari's will be sent home with
aemond and vegar right behind him now
most of you should already know what
happens after this
the rain fell in sheets and great bolts
of lightning lit the world bright as day
arax was struggling to stay aloft in the
Gale when a raw shook the very
foundations of Storm's end
Eamonn Rose through the clouds and Below
him the Monstrous Vega Vega was five
times the size of araks and the hardened
Survivor of a hundred battles vegar
caught him above shipbreaker Bay
Watchers on the castle wall saw distant
blasts of flame and heard a shriek drown
out the Thunder
Prince lucaris fell broken to be
swallowed by the waves
with his death the war of ravens came to
an end
and the war of Fire and Blood began
although I already have a very good idea
of what will happen I'm really looking
forward to seeing how all of this will
get brought to life in the final episode
of House of the dragon's first season
let me know if you've already seen the
new episode I will be making another
video about the final episode once I've
finally seen it for myself like I've
said before I will be making videos
during the whole off season if you have
followed me since the days of Game of
Thrones then you know I make videos
during the entire year even when the
show is off the air so hopefully all of
you will stick around because I will
always have a lot more videos heading
your way now let me know what you think
down below leave me some of your
thoughts about the new photos as well as
the final episode if you've already seen
it as always I want to thank all of you
for stopping by and showing some love I
hope all of you have a great day I will
see you again very soon bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign